what kind of info is there in this
University it is all of my social media
marketing knowledge you know the last
two years of my life has been consumed
by like mastering social media
algorithms and perfecting short form
content so I've done tons of different
businesses um I ran a web 3 business or
regenerated just under five million
dollars I ran you know the account for a
stand-up comedian he started selling out
shows I've built up a massive personal
brand for myself multiple others so I'm
just teaching all those tips and how you
can integrate it into your business
because it applies to literally any
business you can think of making content
along with it understanding social media
and how to get millions of views for
free is the best knowledge you can know
right now and that's what I teach why
you're here genuinely as Caitlin Bennett
not as what Amanda Jenna whatever why
are you here name is not Jenna please
don't assume I am assuming I'm
identifying as Jenna okay but your
name's Caitlyn why are you here no I'm
identifying this General
your name is Caitlyn why are you here so
please respect me and my person Jenna my
name is Jenna and my pronouns are they
in them respective
I would respect your pronouns no matter
what I'm asking you why you're here
don't call me Caitlyn I'm identifying as
Jenna that if you know he's just playing
their game she's just playing their game
except she's being facetious and they're
serious I mean she is just playing their
game like they they do the same [ __ ] so
she really is just giving it back when
wine on me tonight sling why wow wow
thank you sling anything about gender
identity you know that's not how it
works
okay yeah I'm done talking to you you
don't understand what you're talking
about you know what you're respecting me
I'm not a bigot I am right guys we have
a bigot right here won't respect me and
what I want to be called and what I'm
identifying again
go to info
[Music]
oh she's on Infowars
prompt arrangement Center it starts with
liver failure and then it causes brain
damage everybody here has brain damage
today to her I just didn't know her name
I like her that's so funny she's funny
oh by the way we're making an exclusive
video just for Discord and Rumble so
make sure to follow me there we're
reacting to Alex Jones
his craziest takes like super conspiracy
[ __ ] that wouldn't yeah that wouldn't
fly on YouTube so make sure to follow
join my Discord and follow us on Rumble
okay my [ __ ] is normal I don't know I
don't know anything until I show up
that's great all right Eric thanks for
the 10. hi Rick what are you what are
you thank you
[ __ ] what you go around harassing are
you okay you come here I don't look like
I'm all right there man
no
it's really good for their health
obesity kills more people every year
than Firearms this is my bestie she goes
everywhere that is pretty hilarious yeah
that's that's some Savage [ __ ] she is a
Savage you're with me
I have mind control I'm not even telling
them to do it and they're doing
everything I'm thinking you guys are
doing mind control I don't even have to
tell them to do it and they do
everything I think the Rally's over
let's go
your presence just cancel the rally
like your tits on Instagram do you like
them because no you mentioned them you
were thinking about it I'm actually like
you're thinking about him am I though
you mentioned them what do you think
about that this dude he's
thinking about my tits that's so gross
I'm thinking about it oh this is just
Fringe like I when people talk to me
like that like you like oh it just
reminds me of when you're in like second
third grade
a lot of these people whether we want to
acknowledge it or not are going to
outgrow this and look back on these
videos and cringe you're thinking about
my boobs maybe there's some content as
much as we are okay yes of course
there's always contact yeah yeah so like
yeah you're right nope you're right
big facts
you're pretty good they're pretty good
right yeah
okay I get it yeah I don't know very
cute we're at a pride parade a lot of
gay girls around so I get it
Justin be on the lookout it's
nothing to worry about
look violent and nasty
because I can be here it doesn't matter
I'm here to talk to people like her that
have been the most respectful people
I've ever met in my life
they're making a shrine around me right
now
[Laughter]
where she is
this whole parade is now about me
very taller you guys
no it's not tolerant you love the
attention I think all these people are
dressed
screaming in the streets
attention look at the doggy the dog's
got a cone on his head it's very sad he
cut his leg something bad right down to
the muscle
really need to work on your manners your
tolerance you
okay
so this girl right here just tried to
steal a hat from someone
who's waiting on the Alfredo what is in
your mouth oh wow you're scary I don't
want your spit on me honestly no if you
can stop the yelling and spitting I
would I would gladly come over be mad
that people like you are ignorant to the
point that you have no idea what people
are paying in taxes okay this is really
funny because this woman literally had
to start a conversation with us
strangers by asking it for trumpsters
and when we said no and she is awesome
and when they said when we said no it
was yes I'm so glad I would never just
walk up Scholars are paying forever
People's Health Care well guess what
that's the way it works that's why
Medicare for all will work because if
everybody plays their take that health
care and go get checked because you're
spitting on what
what did you say she said take that
health care and go get checked because
you're spitting on me as she pulled away
she is a funny broad she's very funny
this girl and she's pretty I like her
she's smart and pretty and funny it's
called her funniest moments guys not her
most productive moments so that does
make sense why none of this is
productive
oh you guys you got it you got it good
actually a really big whistle no thank
you oh why not
okay why are you whistling
not interested thank you so okay I
figured out if I go up to them and ask
them to give me a big whistle they'll
just stop whistling and then everybody
can hear Trump like they want to isn't
it kind of sad that you guys are
outnumbered probably by 50 000 people
are you here to report or to
editorialize editorialized oh good
um no I don't think so you're not
outnumbered no I don't think it's sad
okay oh it's not sad no it's not that
you don't think that maybe it's not
popular that you guys have a baby Trump
balloon
Trump's event
this was Trump's event
you guys came out to it to support Trump
thank you for supporting you're so
clever thank you
[Music]
thank you I guarantee
guaranteed
now in this in this out of context clip
she didn't ask any tough questions but I
guarantee if she did say can you explain
at least one policy that you disagree
with that Donald Trump has proposed or
enacted she wouldn't be able to
articulate by chance no chance
yes I'm known for your honesty yes very
good very good not like seeing it thank
you so much
every single day at infowars.com show
make sure you check that out make sure
you support us make sure you go to the
store infowarstore.com she loves it
these people are so weird why do you go
to a rally and then just really oh okay
no no no no no no no no no no no go go
go I get we get excited we this is what
we do base mom cuts off Sunny what was I
saying now wow it's so weird why do you
go there to just scream so loud that
dick you can't even hear the person talk
or you're not even gonna listen to what
the guy has to say that's what these
people do you see do white do right
Wingers ever go to leftist realities and
just scream I don't know because I don't
watch the channels that show that but
yeah I do think that there are I know
there are crazy you right Wingers that
do crazy [ __ ]
so we can't we can't pretend that this
is just a them problem that's the they
them problem
[Laughter]
s
look at her look at that face
were murdered
very cool she loves info words
[Applause]
[Music]
what's Trump doing over here
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my favorite house
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wow the media really is amazing at
changing people's minds they do a great
job
I need a media password
my name is Jenna Granny's gone wild I
identify as Jenna that was funny good
job Caitlyn that was hilarious what do
you give Caitlin one to ten oh Caitlyn's
got a 10 for me everything I've ever
seen from her in the past has been so
entertaining that was pretty funny NGS
[Music]
yeah the feelings
[Music]